going into game number two they're a
game and a half out of first place in
the national league east and they really
needed that one because the pitching
didn't hold up the way they had expected
but the offense which had struggled
early on came to life he's making his
fourth start of the year
you know this is a game where you hope
the offense wins it for you not that
vince isn't capable
but you know you'd like to be able for
vince to settle down and be able to
cruise through a few innings all right
so here's our ooze who will lead it off
hitting 240 with no home runs five runs
better than did not play in game one
and it's a three pitch strikeout for
velasquez one out here in the first
that's it
just as hard as you can for as long as
you can
with two outs it'll bring jd martinez to
the plate
fastball
and a strike three calls i think he just
surprised him with that no runs one hit
and a man left
yeah he threw good last time out against
toronto four innings only gave up one
run fastball and a couple different
sliders slow one and a quick one
and a big swing and a miss he comes up
empty
mazda starts with a strikeout brings d.d
gregorius up
that one gets away from griot and here
comes rhys hoskins he'll score and the
phillies take a one-nothing lead here in
the first inning
it's not a surprise the phillies now
have scored 33 runs in the first inning
of games
wow deedee might as well drive in jt
oh it's looped out to center field
that's going to drop for a basin
rounding third is jt real muto the throw
to the plate cut off and now dini's
caught between first and second he could
have gone back to first base nobody was
there but he's tagged out
now the phillies will settle for the two
runs here in the first
zoo wayland will check in at 167.
he serves that one at a left center
field for a base hit jackie bradley jr
coming home to score
zooey lynn as an rbi single and the sox
get on the board here in the second
that's a good battle by lin because that
was not an easy pitch to make contact on
him alex baum the hero of game one with
the walk-off two-run single in the
seventh inning
tied him up high and tight 92 miles an
hour to strike him out one gone
second strike out of the nine and both
coming on fastballs
neal walker will climb in the d.h here
for the nightcap
it's big swinging a miss there and down
he goes walker fans
swinging a missed strike three and a
nice effort by mazza he strikes out the
side
arrows leads it off
and a call strike three
he's down looking that's four strikeouts
opposite way
going back on it is lynn
at the track curls makes the catch and
the phillies go down in order for second
consecutive innings six retired in a row
for mazza we go to the fourth
and jd martinez
swag it a miss
slider kept on running away
five strikeouts for vince you know nice
little tight slider right there by vince
fallback struck out his first time up
tied him up swinging a miss six
strikeouts for velasquez
david griot popped up his first and only
at-bat
fly ball here down the line he's going
to dunk it down
jackie bradley jr in to score and the
red sox have tied it up yeah crunch me a
beautiful thing right down the line it's
an rbi it's
that is strikeout number eight for vince
that's a season high raphael devers most
rbis before the age of 24
look at the miss he's down on strikes
number nine for vince
got a pretty good total going here
tonight
two outs second and third
[Applause]
out to right field
and lynn
it's the grab of the inning is
zabek will be next bobby has struck out
two times
high fly ball by dalback this one's
going to sail this one is way back it is
gone
bobby dabak has struck again a two-run
homer to put the red sox in the lead
four to two
back toward the middle off the mound
segura's got it throws to first in time
and the side is retired
now rubowski reborn did a nice job he
retired all three hitters
could be first and third with two outs
into right center field down for a base
hit that'll drive in another run
into score xander bogarts down to third
jackie bradley jr
that's three rbis in the nightcap for
bobby d
philly's down to their final out rhys
hoskins will be the hitter
reaches out tags that one right field
backing up lin backing up he makes the
catch he slams into the wall and that's
the ball game